HIS BODY
ZUCCARELLO.
WELL COVER
>> THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT THE
MINNESOTA WILD NEEDED TO
GOES TO THE CORNER, CLASSIC
DEFENDING. ON GOAL.
CAM TALBOT HAS BEEN RAZOR-SHARP
NOT ONLY IN HIS  TWO ON ONE END
MINNESOTA GOES A MAN SHORT FOR
THE SE EACH OF
THOSE GAMES SO IT'S CONCERNING
THIS TREND OFONG THE WAY IT APP
SHOT ORIGINALLY TAKEN RE HAVE B
MISCOMMUNICATION ON THE
DEFENSIVE END, M
NINE MINUTES INTO THE PERIOD.IT
HARTMAN SOMEHOW FLIPPED IT OVER
THE TOP OF THE NET FROM ABABOUT
TALBOT CHECKS THAT'S THE.
RICIN DUMPS IT IN.
TALBOT COULDN'T GET UP WITH THAT
ACROSS TO BRODIN.CAPITALS CAPIT
SPRAYED THE CAPITALS GAME IN A
SHOOTOUT NOWTO FIALA WHO
DUCKS AROUND BEHIND THE NET. THL
CONTROLLED AT CENTERHE HAS IT WO
.
WEEK...TO PUT
IT UNDER.
OR JUST GOING OVER IT LOOKS LIK
HE CAUGHT THE
THIS SECOND SHOOTER FOR BUFFALO
CAUGHT IRON.